quite rightfully everybody's been
talking about their first image of a
black hole which we've ever taken
absolutely amazing but I've been
wondering where actually is it so here
it is if you look into the sky between
the Virgo and Leo constellations just
around here it's just above the horizon
in spring in the northern hemisphere and
in autumn and winter in the southern
hemisphere here is a load of real
astronomical photos stitched together of
the sky we'll zoom into the black hole
it's 50 3.5 million light years away in
the Virgo cluster
[Music]
so this image is obviously a tiny
section of sky but in real terms is
absolutely huge here's what the solar
system would look like if we put it
inside it the mass of this black hole is
a colossal 6.5 billion times the mass of
the Sun and despite the blurry image is
actually at a crazy resolution two
thousand times higher resolution than
the Hubble Space Telescope capturing
this image was only possible because we
made a network of radio dishes that
added up to a virtual telescope the size
of the entire Earth so the engineering
achievement to get this image is
absolutely insane and a amazing
achievement which is why everyone's so
excited about this and the dark patch in
this image is the first time where we've
seen light being annihilated from the
universe which is so cool actually we we
don't really know what happens to the
light when it falls into a black hole
because we don't have a theory of
quantum gravity but for practical
purposes it's gone forever from this
mega zoom that we did you don't really
get a sense of the geometry of what's
going on so here's another way to
picture where the m87 supermassive black
hole is if you look just above the
ecliptic plane from Earth out of our
solar system past our closest stars out
of the Milky Way past the Local Group of
galaxies it's over here in the Virgo
cluster
I love these images so just for fun
bigger than this is the local
supercluster and bigger than that is the
observable universe and that's
everything apart from the infinite
universe beyond the observable universe
space it's so big
[Music]